[Music]
oh hello
i know right
welcome back everyone it's charlie this
is going to be my new deadpool 3 video
ryan reynolds just dropped a new teaser
to celebrate the anniversary of the leak
of the original deadpool test footage
from way back in comic con 2014
just because we had comic con this past
week so there's a whole bunch of easter
eggs he was talking about deadpool 3
again recently so we'll break it all
down
if you're new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos we'll do
a new amazon giveaway all you have to do
to enter
is be a subscriber and let me know what
you want them to do with deadpool 3
at marvel studios when he posted this he
also dropped a funny joke about why
deadpool 3 is taking so long because
he's
so busy trying to solve the mystery of
the leak even though
it's not really that big of a mystery if
you don't watch a lot of true crime
television it's just that he dropped
this deadpool teaser that's done
in the parody style of unsolved
mysteries with a similar eerie theme
music
if you're not familiar with that tv show
unsolved mysteries is a real tv show
it's been around for forever
the title is self-explanatory it's all
about mysteries that have not been
solved yet
you may remember last year right after
avengers end game as we were heading
into comic con the big marvel phase 4
panel ryan reynolds dropped
this to celebrate and to hype up
deadpool inside the mcu
like where was the leak where did it
come from who did this he even made a
joke about marvel phase 5 because that's
basically the time frame we're talking
about when they would release deadpool 3
just based on all the movies they've
already scheduled through marvel phase
4.
most of you probably remember the
original test footage league but the
whole
joke here in the fact that it's a quote
unquote unsolved mystery is actually
ryan reynolds himself
is the person that leaked the footage
when the footage leaked initially there
were a lot of guesses that people had
about who could have done that
because the whole thing is that when
that happened the project had actually
stalled in development at fox
fox didn't seem like they were
interested in making an r-rated
comedic comic book film they were too
focused on the mainstream x-men films
they were busy hyping up days of future
past and then x-men apocalypse with
brian singer
obviously things did not go down the way
that fox expected them to so ryan
reynolds himself
leaked the test footage it blew up the
internet people went
crazy they've been screaming for a
deadpool movie for so long
pretty much every comic-con for a couple
years before that point people have been
asking where is the deadpool movie
ever since ryan reynolds had played
deadpool during wolverine origins even
though people weren't happy with that
version
even ryan reynolds behind the scenes was
very upset about what they were doing
in fun fact that's not actually ryan
reynolds filming those scenes
at the end of the movie fighting
wolverine with his mouth sewn shut
that's actually a stunt double that was
scott adkins i know because most people
remember him from his batman auditions
because we almost had scott atkins
batman
but he filmed all those martial arts
fight scenes and then they just use
post-production to make it look like
ryan reynolds face so ryan reynolds
didn't even find out about these scenes
till after they had finished him
and just said what the hell is going on
with this cut to several years later he
was finally able to clean up the
timelines in the deadpool 2
post-credits scene and get a little bit
of a hugh jackman cameo even though
technically it's not a new scene it's
not
new hugh jackman footage hey it's me
don't scratch just cleaning up the
timeline
but after that leak happened the rest
was history fox saw the interest so they
green lit the production and then tim
miller and ryan reynolds the rest of the
production people on the team started
making the actual movie
if he's zooming in hands on his little
teaser photo here for deadpool 3 and the
leak you can actually see he put hugh
jackman himself on here like hugh
jackman leaked the test footage he put
blake lively his wife on here
he even put betty white on here too she
was filming promos for the first
deadpool movie but they didn't use her
quite as much for deadpool too
i did a video a little while ago talking
about some deadpool 3 production updates
it's still in development they're still
writing the script as ryan reynolds has
said
marina bacharan who plays vanessa was
also talking about coming back as
vanessa in deadpool 3.
she said that because they're still
writing the script she doesn't know
exactly how her character figures into
deadpool 3
but she would continue with the
franchise josh brolin said he wants to
continue his cable
and kevin feige said way back when we
were still getting hyped up about
infinity war
and thanos he said that it wasn't a big
deal for him to go
from playing the motion captured thanos
to playing live-action cable so it
doesn't sound like kevin feige has any
issues with bringing cable back in the
movies
but as far as i know the only big
character from the first two deadpool
movies that isn't coming back
is actually tj miller he was actually
supposedly out before the movie came out
there were a couple of controversies
going on with him in real life so they
kind of downplayed his character during
deadpool too so if we get to deadpool 3
and you wonder why there's no weasel
even though he was pretty solid in the
first film that's why
wait you look like a trash can full of
[ __ ] was placed on your shoulders and
then
you were in a train fire ryan reynolds
also did a big interview with jimmy
fallon a little while ago too
talking about deadpool in the mcu in the
way that they're trying to figure out
how to fit him in but also keep him
rated r
deadpool also fox deadpool yeah what was
fox and then now it is
in the hands of marvel uh over there at
disney yeah
and what and and can can can those
worlds be
combined or we don't know i don't i see
so much i see infinite possibility in
either version you know if deadpool were
to be in the marvel comic universe i
think
or the marvel cinematic universe rather
i think it would be
explosive and amazing and what a sandbox
to play in
if deadpool continued to get to just do
his own thing and be his own thing
uh also just like infinite possibility
and
you know i mean we have you
i write it i write it with two other
guys rhett reese and paul wernick who
are
geniuses and amazing in you know in so
many ways and
and we just have so much fun we actually
write it all right in here in this room
um where i'm sitting and um and we just
have the best time doing it together so
we hope that we're gonna there's a lot
more to
a lot more story to tell so we hope we
get to do that there's a couple jokes
that you told me about i won't say now
because i don't want to ruin it's in the
third one but
it didn't make it to the second one but
it was really
a really funny thing that was going on i
was like oh
they'll never let you do that yeah you
could fill a gymnasium with some of the
jokes that got cut out of deadpool one
and two
that would get us all arrested or turned
into some sort of
disney liquid so as you can tell from
what ryan reynolds is saying like
everybody is really excited about doing
deadpool 3.
marvel is excited about it kevin feige
is excited about it even the disney ceo
is excited about deadpool the reason why
you just haven't heard about them
actually putting it on the schedule why
there's no marvel phase 4 deadpool 3
movie
is because way before the fox deal was
done they'd already mapped out
all their marvel phase 4 movies so there
weren't any actual open release dates
for them to do it until
marvel phase 5 and because the virus
pushed all the marvel phase 4 movies by
a year we're now into like
late 2022 2023 and 2024 before they
could even think about releasing
deadpool 3.
so that's the simple reason why it's
taking so long what'll probably happen
is as we slowly start to see x-men pop
up in the mcu throughout marvel phase
four and then t's new x-men stuff
then we'll start seeing them talk more
about deadpool 3
but just because it's going to take him
a couple years to get to the actual
movie doesn't mean that they'll wait
that long to introduce deadpool to the
mcu
he can still always cross over with some
other person's movie in some funny
post-credit scene or a funny cameo scene
but like ryan reynolds and a lot of the
other people the writers have said
typically when you would think about
deadpool in somebody else's mcu movie
which are typically pg-13
he wouldn't be quite as foul-mouthed or
quite as hardcore
more like the once upon a deadpool
version of deadpool just making way more
disney way more avengers way more
spider-man jokes
you have to imagine now that he's in the
mcu they have free reign for him to
reference
anything that's ever happened in an mcu
movie
in part of the fun of the character is
that he doesn't always totally make
sense like the way he made fun of
both of the different eras of x-men
films during the first deadpool film are
you talking about mcavoy or stuart
these timelines are so confusing he can
totally do that for marvel now
and for everyone that's been clamoring
for a deadpool kills the marvel universe
movie
i feel like it would be a slam dunk
opportunity for them to at least
joke about deadpool killing the fox
marvel universe in deadpool 3 even if
that's not the actual movie itself
just have them kill off all the
characters that they're going to recast
for the mcu
and they just treat it like it's in an
alternate universe by just assuming they
can do
anything that they want and deadpool 3
is often its own little bubble of
continuity
what do you want them to do for the
story of deadpool 3
there's a bunch of stuff left over from
comic-con that i haven't made videos for
yet that i'll try to get to
umbrella academy season 2 is also
premiering on netflix
tomorrow so i'll try to do some videos
for that as well everyone click here for
the umbrella academy season 2
episode 1 opening scene it feels like
it's right out of an x-men movie
and click here for that brand new marvel
hellstrom trailer in doctor strange 2
easter eggs
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe i'll see you guys tonight
[Music]
you